- Making movies is eating a sandwich of.
And the only thing that
gets a little better
is as the years go by you
get a little more brave.
But is always there.
It was very well meaning.
Why don't you take out the violence
so you can reach a wider audience?
I said 'cause I don't
want a wider audience.
I want the audience for the movie.
I come from a country
where you didn't make money
because you made movies, you
lost money as you made movies.
And I was trembling and I was really moved
because a, I was happy the
movie was being recognized
and b, I was not going to jail.
- He's a Mexican film
director, screenwriter,
producer and novelist.
He's had a lifelong
fascination with monsters
which he considers to be
creatures of great power.
His work can be characterized
as a strong connection
between fairy tales and horror.
He's Guillermo Del Toro
and here is my take
on his top ten rules for success.
Rule number one is my personal favorite
and make sure to stick
around all the way to end
for some special bonus clips.
Also as he talking if he says something
that really resonates with you,
please leave it in the comments below
and put quotes around it so other people
can be inspired as well.
Enjoy.
(upbeat music)
- It started in the crib, I
was a baby and from the crib
all the way to age 11 more or less,
I had what is called lucid dreaming
which means you dream that you are awake.
- Hola?
- So I literally saw monsters.
I was used to monsters,
I love them but you know
at the very early age
I made a deal with them
to allow me to go to the bathroom
because I was so afraid I
ended up peeing my crib.
And you know, we stayed friends.
You know there are only two
things you can do in art
or in narrative in storytelling,
you can tell about the good stuff in life
which has always been very boring to me
and you can tell stories
about the dark side of life
which has been much more attractive to me.
When I talk to pre-first time filmmakers
or first time filmmakers,
I always tell them
look, making movies is
eating a sandwich of.
And the only thing that
gets a little better
is as the years go by you
get a little more brave.
But the is always there.
- [Interviewer] But isn't
that true of life also?
- I think it is, I use
another metaphor for life.
But for film, I tell you that one fits.
- [Interviewer] And in the
end somehow you find joy.
- Well you end up convincing
yourself it's peanut butter.
- [Interviewer] And is
it ever peanut butter?
- I want to believe it is.
- [Interviewer] But do you look
back and go yes I did that--
- I tell you without a
doubt, we may say this way,
it's the greatest, being an
artist in whatever discipline,
dance, painting, theater,
whatever you want.
It's the greatest work on earth.
I mean, it's truly disheartening
in this way or that way
but so is every job.
So is every job.
When I was younger I worked
with my father on real estate
for five years, I was the worst
car salesman in the history
of car salesmanship--
- [Interviewer] You were too honest?
- Yeah, people would come
and say what about this?
I was , you know Glengarry Glen Ross,
I would not get the knife set,
I would be the Shelley Levene.
I would be out, out.
It was terrible, my father
said you are terrible.
The other vendors whenever I
went out the other salesman,
whenever I went out to
client, they actually
laughed behind my back, actually
physically were laughing
behind my back and I was the worst.
But in real estate I was good.
I was good on real estate.
And my father used to
say, you have to do this
to show that you can
have an honest living,
do an honest living, and what
I did is work on real estate
in the mornings and I did
monsters in the afternoon.
But I know that when you have a real job,
I painted highways one
summer in Wichita, Kansas,
I mean a real job has equal
heartbreak and stuff like that
and all the things.
- [Interviewer] I think
it's one of the things
people really misunderstand is as glorious
it is to do the things
you're passionate about
and to be an artist, it's still a job.
- Oh it's still a job.
- [Interviewer] It's still work.
- Yeah, yeah, it is but God
bless anyone that can do this
is beautiful and you have
to truly be grateful.
And the only way to
remain objective about how
grateful you need to be
is present your present
to your past self when
you're 20 years old.
And if you go and talk to
yourself at 20 years old
and said would you like
to be doing this movie,
with this budget, what do
you think your response
at this training would be,
absolutely yes, you know?
I think that financial
success is not success.
You know to me when
people say, for example,
I showed Pan's Labyrinth
and somebody said,
why don't you take out the violence
and it was very well
meaning, why don't you take
out the violence so you
can reach a wider audience?
Because I don't want a wider audience,
I want the audience for the movie.
Each movie has an audience that's it.
It's not going to get more or less.
If you with it, if you
amputate it, if you cripple it.
That's all do.
You know people dream of a bigger audience
and I go, but is it the movie?
If in order to make more people happy
the Cinderella doesn't
get the prince at the end,
I don't know, it's not the same tale.
As much as I like the Disney
films of the renaissance
of animation, I can't, every
time I see the Little Mermaid
I think but she dies in the book.
She dies at the end, that's
what made it beautiful.
That prince was ultimately so stupid
and I understand they are
reaching a wider audience
but is it the tale Hans
Christian Andersen wrote,
no way, it's a different
movie, it's a different tale.
So if you're asking me was
Little Mermaid successful
as a film, I say it was
but it wasn't the tale.
It's a great, I love those
films, I really think
they're beautifully constructed
but it's not the tale.
So Pan's Labyrnith without the violence
is not Pan's Labyrinth.
It is I don't know, it's a
fantasy like Harry Potter
or Naria or any other fantasy film.
And you know when they say,
I would like you to do this
for me and I produce a lot
of first time filmmakers,
but I don't produce all
first time filmmakers
that approach me, I say look if I say no
and you give up, I'm sorry to tell you,
it's the wrong job for you.
'Cause you live with rejection for decades
sometimes as a director
and you end up making
the movie you want to make.
So if I say no, that
doesn't mean I'm right
or I'm wrong, you just say
him I'll show him later,
I'm going to make it and that fat bastard
is going to have say, I was
so wrong and hit himself
in the head because he didn't do it
and I think that's the thing to do.
Show us, don't tell us, do the thing.
And if you do them wrong,
what you do on your on terms,
that's how I define success,
failing in your own terms.
I come from a country
where you didn't make money
because you made movies, you
lost money as you made movies.
And all of my life, when
I approach a new product
and I'm 50 years old and
I don't know how many
has producer, director, and
I still have the same emotion
when I go into a project,
I go how much am I willing
to lose to do that image.
And there's always one or
two images in every project
that you would mortgage
your house, sell your car,
give everything you have to make sure
that image comes to safe--
- Yeah I've heard you
talk about Pacific Rim,
it was the girl with the red shoes.
- Absolutely.
- You like had to make that
movie just to see that.
- It doesn't matter what you go through.
Doesn't matter if they
give you x amount of time,
you need to always protect
the images that are crucial.
(man speaking in Spanish)
- [Interviewer] What did
Cronos achieve for you?
- Well that movie changed
my life because we were
more than the underdog,
more than the dark horse,
we were a movie that
nobody wanted to produce,
nobody was supporting except
my producers in Mexico.
And we suddenly were selected for Cannes
and literally we were all of a sudden
one of the most awarded movies
in Mexican film history.
I remember the first time
Cronos won, the first award,
which was a cash award.
- Oh.
- And before that award we were
in debt for half a million.
We won the award and literally
like a beauty contest,
I was crying, crying on the
stage holding this giant check.
And I was trembling and I was really moved
because a, I was happy the
movie was being recognized
and b, I was not going to jail.
I used to do makeup effects for my stuff.
They were very bad but I
was the only one doing them.
So a lot of friends when
I was in my short films
they would see the effect and say,
who did that for you and I say, I did it.
And they started telling
me, would you do mine
and I started doing it and I realized
there was an edge with which
going to feature films.
And what I did was for
example, we did a TV series
called Hora Marcada which
a terrible filmmaking
but we were all learning,
Alfonso Cuaron was there,
I was there, Emmanuel Lubezki the DP,
Guillermo Narvarro, my DP, all
of us started in that series
and we were doing little experiments
and I said to the producers,
I'll do the makeup effects
for free, you pay the
materials I do them for free
but in exchange, I write
and direct episodes
and they said that's a good deal.
So it was a way to put
your foot in the door.
And I was already on the way to do Cronos.
I started writing Cronos around 1985
and I knew that in order
to make the device,
the Cronos device and the makeup effects,
I needed to create a
company that would tell
the producers there's someone
that can do those effects.
So soon as I leave Cronos
essentially a year later,
the shop was closed because
it had served it's purpose.
- What's some stuff that
aspiring filmmakers can do
to separate themselves from
the herd, from the noise.
- Well I think be themselves.
I mean, you can be hard to
peg, some people may like you,
some people may not like you,
some people get what you do,
some others think you're crazy
but if you're true to yourself
if you only do things
that you really believe in
and that are personal
to you, then you know
you don't need the
approval of anybody else.
- Right.
- That's in my opinion what distinguishes,
not only the great horror filmmakers
but the great filmmakers in general.
Some people can go through
life shooting B movies
and eventually they get discovered
you know by an audience that
caught them at the right time.
Some people go all their lives
shooting sort of underground
little things and they
can find their audience.
And it's a matter of being true.
Not trying to be somebody
else or have some different
type of budget, I mean
you'll find your audience,
and your audience will find you.
I think what I strive
to is to connect deeply
with audiences that like what I do
even if the audience at
large does or doesn't,
it makes no difference to me.
I make weird movies no matter
what size the movie is.
And they're not for everyone.
And a lot of people may be puzzled or say,
why did you do this but I only do things
that I hope speak to somebody
in the same (mumbles) way
was spoken to by people that
got high on their own supply.
'cause I get high on my own supply.
I make the movies because I want them.
And whether it is robbers
and monsters duking it out
or it's a post-war fable, whatever it is,
they're done because I want to see them.
Happiness is a very
difficult thing to define.
I think it's fleeting,
you know, and I think
that it's, I'm the
happiest when I'm working,
and you know a project of
mine but even then, you know,
I think it's a rhythm.
I think you get into a rhythm of work
and personal life that
you feel balanced about.
But I think happiness is
sort of too chirpy a term
to try to achieve, that
sounds like perfection.
Both seem to me, equally
unattainable at its purest
you know, I think you find peace.
I think that's what I would
look for than happiness.
- [Interviewer] Where on
a set do you find moments
of great pleasure in the process?
- Oh yes, discovering it is happiness.
Whenever you see something that you wrote
and re-wrote for six,
seven years come to life,
it's just beautiful and
you're completely content
and you feel fulfilled and it's magical.
And it sounds like a cliche but it's true.
Or when you see an actor in
wardrobe, make up, everything
completely come into the
set for the first time
is purely magical.
I mean, there are many
things that are like that.
In the course of discovering
or when you are with
an actor and something doesn't work.
Or with a camera and
something doesn't work
and you find the solution and it's better
than what you wanted to do first.
Those are moments of great happiness.
I've never thought of my
work or my life as a career.
That's why I have doubts so many times.
I want the right to up.
That's the only inalienable
right of a human beng
is to up and I cherish the screw ups.
So you know, I'm going to continue up
in the same way I've been
up since the beginning
and the only problem is
of quality I can give you.
You're going to get the
same from the same guy
with the same earnestness
and I'm never going to worry
about salary or career
or like that, I can't.
I'm genetically engineered
to do my own thing you know.
And that's what, if I
had been more malleable
I have never given my version
of what happened on Mimic
but I fought and won the
war, lost a lot of battles,
but won the war and it
was a very tough war
and it was a very
frontal war and I learned
the value of identity in that process.
And I tell you that's the
only thing I'm concerned with.
I don't respond to the world.
They say we're going to pay
you 10 million to direct
an action, a straight action film.
Can you imagine that,
waking up every morning
and going to shoot a movie,
that's like, you know,
not having a boner and going
to a sex show every day
for work, what do you do?
Are you going to show up and
you're going to (mumbles).
That's the same thing.
- [Evan] Pan's Labyrinth
is a project Del Toro
had no problem showing up for.
An adult fairy tale with a dark side.
- I think that the movie
comes from a very very dark,
very genuine place in my heart.
And I think that sincerity
always finds an audience,
no matter how small, no matter how large.
Is Pan's Labyrinth going
to be, is it going to make
the same money that Little Nemo did?
No, but whatever audience it touches,
it's going to touch really deeply.
Will Pan find people
that fall in love with it
rabidly in the world, yes.
Will it find people that never understand
what the appeal is, yes.
But it's a film that comes
from a genuine place.
It has the two things that
are absolutely necessary
to make film, balls and heart.
- Thank you so much for watching,
I made this video
because David DJ Pachenco
asked me to so if there's
a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next
leave it in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I also love to know which of
the points you heard today
had the biggest impact on you.
What are you going to take from this video
that you're going to immediately apply
to your life or to your business some how,
leave it in the comments,
I'm curious to see
what you guys have to say.
Finally, I want to give a
quick shout out to Armen.
Armen thank you so much
for picking up a copy
of my book, Your One
Word and for reading it
while having your soup as
well, I appreciate that.
I hope you're enjoying the book
and thank you for the support.
Thank you guys again for watching,
I believe in you, I hope you continue
to believe in yourself, aim
whatever your one word is,
much love, I'll see you soon.
- I honestly think that a film in complete
and absolute freedom with unlimited budget
is a, impossible and b, undesirable.
I don't think you want that.
I think you want, I think
film is most definitely
an exercise between
desire and restriction.
You need to have, my actor
from Cronos, Frederico Luppi.
He said to me something beautiful
because we were doing a scene and he said,
what do you want me to do here
and I said whatever you
want, it's written for you,
and he said no, I can
only be completely free
if you give me some confines.
He says then within that I'll be free.
And I understood, that was a beautiful way
of putting it and I think that's art.
But certainly filmmaking,
you have, you define those
sort of goals and posts and
you run around in there.
- [Interviewer] So do
you have ideas and go oh,
Guillermo that's too much.
- Oh yes, all the time.
All the time because I
think that your ambition
should always be more than your budget.
It doesn't matter what your budget is.
I remember talking to Alfonso Cuaron
while he was prepping Harry Potter
and he was saying we're
trying to contain it
and he gave me the number,
whatever 120 or 220,
and I went what?
And it's true, you're trying to contain.
In a movie like that you're
still trying to contain.
The myth of people that see a big movie
and say oh, they give me
the money I could do that,
it's a myth, it's entirely a myth,
and it comes with some
absolute lack of knowledge
of how these things operate
because it's a military operation.
And the larger it becomes
still the budget is a monster
and a wall and you're
running a train against it
and you need to know where to stop.
Watch as many movies of
as many eras as you can.
When I was coming up through the ranks,
there was a thing called a cinema club
in the '70s where you threaded 16mm film
and you projected it and I
became familiar with people
that are important to me like (mumbles),
like Laurel and Hardy, the Three Stooges,
you became familiar with Renoir,
you became familiar with everything
from comedy to drama you
can see Preston Sturges,
don't just limit yourself
to what is out there,
or the top 10 at the box
office, that is the main tool,
and live film history because
you are part of that narrative.
Even if it's not film anymore you are
a part of that narrative tradition.
And the second thing
I feel very important,
do not get wrapped in the
industry side of this.
That's what I find really heartbreaking
that people are now a lot of times
you're discussing film
with people that love film
and it's like you're
listening to an agent.
From an agency or the head of a studio,
they know the grosses,
they know who's doing this,
that's absolutely not
important, the important thing
is that tradition you
are going to belong to
and do not get caught on the other side,
stay true to the other side that needs you
and needs to exist and urgently.